went on on women's safety and on phones
and the probation Service First and he
has sort of often gone on physics
questions on one subject but then he
turned it around right towards the end
of his subject he did he started on Zara
Alina's case that woman that was
murdered uh by someone that was not
picked up by the probation service
because as I understand it what his team
was saying was that he wanted to get it
on record that there were failings in
the probation service and what was the
government going to do about that to
ensure that this terrible crime couldn't
happen again and the Prime Minister did
accept the findings of the report he
then used that later though uh to
broaden that out as well into sort of a
competence question in the government
um the main parts of the exchange of
course were around Nadeem zahawi as we
thought it would be and kirstarma
they're kicking off with a question and
uncomfortable question for the Prime
Minister saying any politician who seeks
to avoid taxes in this country isn't fit
to be in charge of tax payer money now
the Prime Minister as we talked about
before prime minister's questions uh had
a clear defense on that which is I am
following due process I appointed an
independent advisor I'm following due
processor UK starma are taking political
opportunities platoonism here because
I'm I'm following a process and we
should let that play out now there were
a couple of interesting things in this
between the lines the one is
um the distance that the prime minister
is now put in between him and the dean
zahawi he hid behind the independent
inquiry if you like he didn't in any way
try to defend Nadeem zahari in any of
those exchanges which is something that
might predict my ears and indeed he said
it would have been political expedient
of me to get that uh inquiry resolved
before midday on Wednesday presumably
because he could therefore either uh put
the story to bed and Sack uh his
chairman or he the chairman would be
exonerated but there was no sense of
trying to defend Nadim zahari he was now
into the it's a process that's a very
different position from a week ago the
other thing I thought was interesting in
terms of Kirsten going back to
competence is that he reiterated the
this is a weak prime minister who won't
sack his chairman but then he expanded
that to say when you look at the system
the problems in the police system and
probation when you look at the NHS does
the Prime Minister think that this job
is too big for him and that was a new
attack actually let's listen to it
I believe in proper due process
[Applause]
that's why
that's why I
append an advisor is doing his job but
the opposition can't have it both ways
Shadow leader
is also his party chair both
me and the gov to appoint an independent
advisor and now he objects to that
independent advisor doing their job in
it's simple political opportunism and
everyone can see through it
[Music]
we all
knows his party chair questions about
family finances and tax avoidance
his
his failure
his failure to sack him when the whole
country could see what's going on shows
how hopelessly weak he is
a prime minister overseeing chaos
overwhelmed at every turn
he can't say when ambulances will get to
heart attack victims again he can't say
when the prison system will keep streets
safe again he can't even deal with tax
avoiders in his own cabinet
starting to wonder if this job is just
too big for him
[Applause]
prime minister's questions now isn't it
there's this weakness that he perceives
in the Prime Minister a weakness but he
went farther there because there was
you're too weak to take decisions be
that Gavin Williamson who actually then
resigned from government be that
dominant Rob another cabinet minister
also under investigation up to eight
bullion allegations will be that now
deem Sahari but what was interesting
about that was kier's starmer went
farther he said does it make you think
the NHS isn't working the probation
service is not keeping women safe on the
streets are you up to the job and the
reason that that is quite
um my heart might prick a bit is that
the whole Rishi sunak operation and the
beginning of the launch of the year and
his big speech of the five promises to
the public around the economy and small
boats and cutting waiting lists is that
I'm competent I have integrity and I'm
competent now kirstarma keeps going at
Rishi sunak on integrity and what you
saw there is now he's beginning to
attack him on competence and it makes me
wonder what sort of polling is is labor
seeing and is this going to become a
more frequent attack line the the other
thing I quickly say Jane as you saw in
those exchanges and I thought Rishi
sooner looked uncomfortable was that
starmer and I thought he would do this
use that to bring up the issue of Rishi
sunat's wife former non-dom status she
changed her tax status make that clear
we should make that clear but you
remember he took all of that heat I mean
you asked him about some of the issues
around that yourself he took all of the
that heat in the run-up to the
leadership contest over that and then
kirstama rays in that saying maybe you
won't want to talk about family tax
Affairs so taking another dig at him and
what this all is is the prime minister
these were not his decisions around and
deem Sahara we've been appointed
Chancellor while there was a tax case it
was Boris Johnson but he is now having
to absorb the Fallout of that but I
think there's a second issue for him
there which is
it was known in the summer of last year
that there were questions around Nadim
zahawi's tax status because newspapers
were writing about it I wish you sooner
might not have known the details but he
did appoint him with some of that
information in the public domain so if
you were being critical you might say
why didn't you ask those questions
whatever the Rights and Wrongs of what
happened he now has a political problem
on his plate I mean the thing to say is
that number 10 do want this dealt with
swiftly and you can absolutely see why
because it's not going to go away until
it's resolved